let's go to our color from the 64:6 area
code always good to not on Boston area
codes get on quickly but also New York
area codes get on quickly because I like
hearing from people in our former
broadcast center New York City although
some people just have New York City cell
phones and they're like in California a
lot of people live in New York City to
now six for six tell me who's this and
what's on your mind today
hey David it's me Dominique the French
New Yorker Ledesma I wanted to talk to
you about it actually it's funny of the
conversations you've been having really
go perfectly with what we were talking
about last time I remember about the
brainwashing in Oklahoma yes yes I was
going to call you back to talk about
this um and I think the elections kind
of show the hesitancy that some people
have in these birds matter on suburban
areas and rural areas where people are
afraid to vote actually afraid to vote
for Democrats I think part of the
brainwashing is has to do without a lot
with religion and the idea that somehow
they're bad people and that they have to
be good people and that people have to
behave a certain way and I just find it
very bizarre like that you would vote to
stop for somebody who's going to tell
you you don't deserve $15 an hour you
don't deserve healthcare companies have
the right to under pay you pay you below
the inflation rate which means that
you'll struggle really hard in life and
you'll have a very small chance of
getting out of it and somehow for them
that's okay as long as you don't rob
money from the rich and their idea
robbing money from the rich is being
paid properly getting health care and
they actually believe that it's immoral
to do these things and and I think it
has a lot to do with the way they've
been brought up with with religion and
feeling that you know if you you you you
show yourself to be a good Christian
yeah and and you know and if you don't
show yourself to be a crude Christian
then you kind of deserve what you get
and yeah this is basically something
we've talked about which is called
strict father morality which is when you
take a look at an issue and you say
listen all the facts point to this
should be the position all the evidence
points to this is how people should be
voting what you need to add in to
understand why people vote the way they
do is this thing called strict father
morality and a great example is
contraception right if you want an
abortion you claim to want to prevent
abortions we know that access to
contraception and sex education and
teaching safe sex reduces the number of
pregnancies which reduces the number of
abortions so clearly they should all be
in favor of that but what's the x-factor
it's the fact that fundamentally a lot
of those voters believe that if you have
recreational non-procreative sex
you deserve to end up and you're making
a proper salary I'll add that into what
you're saying
yes absolutely Dominika I appreciate the
call thank you so much it's very very
good to hear from you as always and we
will talk about strict father morality
another time I think maybe not the right
right time today